hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll all of us are
faced with difficult decisions in our
lives big decisions we don't know
whether to do something or not because
the ramifications of doing it or not
might just be enormous right getting
married going to graduate school getting
a new job moving across the country
other sort of life-changing decisions
but we generally think that even though
it might be difficult to make these
decisions the underlying strategy of
being rational is not that hard to
understand we have preferences right we
might like learning new things but we
might not like working really hard so
there's something in favor of going to
graduate school and something against
going to graduate school so here's the
problem
imagine that you are considering a kind
of life choice that will literally
change who you are the kind of choice
that is so big that the person after the
choices made is a different person than
you are now before the choices made
these are called transformative
experiences and today's guest Lori Paul
is the world's expert she's a
philosopher at Yale University who's
written about transformative experiences
and she's raised the following issue you
might just say well okay I'm gonna make
some big change I'll become a different
person but I can just look at other
people who've done that other people
who've gone to grad school or gotten
married or whatever I will ask them how
they feel about it the problem is that
how your response is after you've made
the change might not be relevant to your
preferences now because you are a
different person and you might not know
after you've made the change you might
not be able to remember what it was like
to be you the fanciful example that she
uses is becoming a vampire right I mean
you can ask vampires how do they like it
and they'll say sure we love being
vampires but the things that they like
about it might not be things that are
relevant to your preferences right now
so how do we adapt rationality to the
case of transformative experiences when
our selves change over time and of
course once you open up this Pandora's
box you have very interesting things to
ask about what it means to change over
and what it means to have a personal
identity even though you as a person are
not the same person now that you were
five years ago or will be five years
from now so I don't think we find the
once and for all answers here but it's a
it's a really fascinating conversation
about a set of issues that we all face
without kind of even knowing it so
thanks for supporting the mindscape
podcast remember we have a web page at
preposterous universe comm slash podcast
and something I always mean to remind
people of but always forget is there's a
mailing list so probably the podcast
just pops up into your podcast listener
device whatever that might be but if you
want you can get an email every time a
new episode comes out it's a MailChimp
mailing service but go to the website
you can click on join the mailing list
there's both a regular mailing list for
episodes and in principle there's
another mailing list for announcements
there's never been an announcement but
you never know it could happen thanks
for being part of the mindscape
community and with that let's go
[Music]
Lori Paula from the mindscape podcast hi
Sean it's nice to be here so we're gonna
be talking about transformative
experiences I think this is a unusual /
challenging topic a little bit because
unlike you know quantum mechanics where
no one thinks they know what's going on
this is something where there are some
challenging ideas that people should
think about but they probably all think
they know what the right answer is right
away right have you right encountered
that and in talking about this yeah and
one place because the phrase
transformative experience has a sort of
ordinary interpretation and that one
what I want to talk about isn't
completely different from that it's
deeply related to that but has some
important nuances yeah often do I have
to have a discussion back and forth
where people think they might know about
it and I think they do kind of know
about it but maybe a little more there's
some detail we already get into right
it's what the law servers do right so so
maybe to ease the path there why don't
you just give us the punchline why does
give us the elevator pitch for like what
we're talking about and then we can back
up and get there in a more detailed way
okay so the way that I want to think
about transformative experiences are as
life changing experiences which is the
sort of more ordinary way of thinking
about them but I think there it's we
have to be more specific than that
because there are lots of life changing
experiences we have that don't surprise
us in certain ways or don't necessarily
teach us new things in the ways that I'm
interested in the concept of
transformative experience that I'm
especially interested in applies to like
a set of very specific big life changes
and often they're changes that we face
when we're at life's crossroads mm-hm
and one way I like to think about it is
in terms of decision making so I'll
frame it in terms of decision-making
here but it's not just about making
decisions so if you had the chance like
a one-time-only chance let's say to
become a parent or my favorite example
is to become a vampire yeah we're
definitely talked about the vampire I
can't all right so how do I tell you
about vampires because that's my
favorite choice okay see it Dracula
comes to you you're touring a castle
somewhere and you know somewhere in
Europe and he says look I like the way
you carry yourself I want to make you
one of mine
you find this kind of stunning and
exciting a little frightening and so he
says a little bit more he says well look
you know you'll be able to have amazing
new powers and you'll look amazing in
black and you'll be one of my legions
and you'll never you know you'll be for
all important ways you'll be you know
relatively am immortal I mean okay
barring sunlight and so this is
incredibly exciting so okay so here's an
amazing opportunity you rush back to
your Airbnb and you call your mom and
your mom says oh that's interesting well
I'm already a vampire and you say mom
this is you know why don't you tell me
so okay so after things calm down you
start asking your questions about what
it's like and what she thinks you should
do because you're worried because you
know that vampires can't go out in the
Sun some downsides yeah
yeah and they drink blood and that's
kind of gross and they have no soul or
whatever right and she tries to tell you
about it she says well you know what she
tries to tell you like why she thinks it
would be a great thing for you to do he
can't really kind of get the detail you
need she says well it's really amazing
it's really incredible and then she
finally says after you talk for a bit
well look you know it's just something
that you as a human can't possibly
understand you have to have the
experience yourself to find out it's
humans can't really understand what it's
like to be a vampire it's only it's a
vampire thing mm-hmm
okay so and actually so okay you trust
your mom and you check around you text
some friends and you find out in fact
that actually everybody you know has
become a vampire
and pretty much you have the same
conversation to everyone else about well
should I do it one of the pros and cons
and they say there are some pros and
there's some cons but you don't really
care about the cons and it's fabulous
you should do it okay so here's this
one-time only chance to have this
amazing experience that you can't in
some ways know and very important ways
to know what it's like unless you
undergo it now that's the transformative
experience it's a kind of experience
that you can't know about until you
undergo it and clearly becoming a
vampire is life-changing
life changing space it changes in a very
deep and fundamental sense who you are
now I framed it in terms of like having
an opportunity to do this so there was a
decision and I find that very helpful
because there's the idea of a
transformative experience some of them
kind of come to us unbidden sure we can
talk about that but sometimes we have a
choice about whether to undergo the
vampire thing is clearly a very thinly
veiled metaphor for having kids maybe
even yes exactly because you're up all
night exactly so that's exactly right so
I use it in other discussions as a kind
of thought experiment outline the
conceptual structure of a real-life kind
of case where you have this one time
only maybe not I want Emily chance to
become a parent because maybe you could
become a parent more than once but it's
your first time let's say and so you're
facing this new kind of experience that
you have to actually undergo you have to
actually have a child and form that life
changing kind of parental a loving
attachment bond with a particular child
that you produced who really know what
it's gonna be like to live your life
with that child as that's the parent of
that child
yeah and it's of course I think life
changing if when you do form that bond
so there's the structure and then when
we think about in terms of decisions
there's actually a special problem that
arises so I'm super interesting
transformative experience
straightforwardly I think they're like
the publisher or sorry they punctuate um
our lives in various kinds of ways and
so they're like the you know I think of
us like if you were just watching like
if you drew a line there at the B be
these like large jumps whenever you had
a transformative experience like think
about your world line like that's where
you're gonna see lots of variation right
in in general and that's already
interesting but if we think about
decision making where we have a picture
of rational decision-making involving
being able to kind of know ahead of time
what sort of act you're performing and
what sorts of outcomes you're deciding
between and in particular knowing enough
about those outcomes to sort of mentally
simulate the possibilities and assign
them values and on that basis choose the
most preferred option
then the cases that I just described
create serious problems for us as
individuals making those choices because
we can't evaluate all the options that
we need to inspect in fact some of the
most important options
we can't evaluate them in the way that
we want to write it means we can't we're
gonna be we're not something like that
yeah two things one is we don't know the
nature of the outcome and then so that
means there's a way in which you can't
reason through it involving a kind of
first personal modeling Molly Crockett
she's a psychologist at Yale has done
really important work on model-based
reasoning and model-free reasoning and a
lot of times when we reason we use for
new things we use model-based reasoning
and I and I think of that in this case
as like imagining myself say being a
parent or being a vampire or just
enjoying the new wing of a house I'm
considering renovating right these are
just things that we do degrees of these
transformative experiences yeah I pick
easy cases for myself like really
radical transformations where there's
this kind of epistemic shift in virtue
of having the new experience that's so
profound that it's getting the players
different things yeah yeah they think
like tasty like that blood is you know
incredibly tasty and there's different
flavors presumably and you know uh I
mean we can it'll I'd the moral question
by having it be artificial or something
like that but it's still pretty gross
right okay so that's the that's what
we're gonna go we're gonna try to figure
out what it means to make choices to
rationally deliberate right
in the presence of these transformative
experiences so because so let's let's
put something on the table that everyone
could just agree with like what is the
ordinary way of thinking about making
rational decisions right the decision
theory or whatever the calculus is let's
let's be a philosopher let's explain to
the folks out there how to make rational
decisions okay so I'm gonna go with I
mean there are lots of different models
and so what I'm trying to do is pick in
some sense the most ordinary generic
way of thinking about this so let's say
you were trying to figure out which pair
of socks to wear one day you get up and
you look and you have three different
pairs of socks you like all of them one
pair is red one pair is blue and one
pair has
I don't know black and white polka dots
right you have interesting socks and so
you set all three pairs of socks out on
your dresser and you observe them and
you have to think about well which pair
of socks would you like to wear and
various kinds of properties are going to
matter for example what color is your
outfit will anyone see your socks you
can know on the inside that you're
wearing polka dots but if you're going
to the airport and you're gonna be
taking off your shoes maybe you might
want to append some maybe just draw
attention to yourselves oh yeah exactly
exactly so so you look at the three
pairs of socks and you assign value to
each like well maybe I'll wear the red
ones maybe I'll wear the blue ones or
maybe I'll wear the polkadot ones and
and each each Act you know and you can
make a choice you can choose the red
ones blue polka dot ones and each each
choice you make has a certain value
right and so you basically and also
we're just assuming I'm not adding in
there can be like how likely is it that
you'll actually be able to wear those
socks well they're all in front of you
so you're okay 100% chance
yes we're keeping it simple you could
feed in pop you know issues about well
when you're thinking about being able to
wear the red socks like couldn't elf
show up immediately and steal them I
ready to try to take them and how likely
is that and people sometimes do have
probabilities involved because in this
case what's easy is that you know the
value of each each choice right of each
outcome and so what you want to do then
is in very in a very simple sense you
want to choose the option it's going to
give you the most value that you want
the most that's going to maximize your
expected value very simply that's the
way so the rational thing to do is to
choose the pair of socks that you like
most
it would seem weird if you really liked
the red socks and you chose the polkadot
socks instead like you're making some
kind of mistake there so you're
maximizing something that you've been
calling a value we could also call it
utility or something like that right
that's the general so and you can
generalize it to situations where
there's a 50/50 chance of different
things happening the expected values
there okay so that's the ordinary
rational way of making decisions now is
this completely unproblematic even
before
you get to transformative experiences
you know I think about I mean let me
just ask you this way is every
decision-making process model Bowl in
terms of maximizing some value or
utility no I mean it's totally
problematic in all kinds of way it's not
like oh yeah I mean there's and there's
a huge amount of debate about whether we
can really well ordinary people don't
act rationally in all kinds of contact
that's all so this model has all kinds
of issues with it I mean we just were
mentioning issues about like the
probability of various outcomes
happening
there's all kinds of crazy things like
what about the radical possibilities
that and you know I don't know that a
mysterious new pair of amazing sparkly
socks could appear just as soon as I
know there's all kinds of you know or
whatever I mean so there are lots of
complications with the model but the
work that I've been doing connecting
with decision theory is intended to
bring kind of it says a new kind of
complication right and a complication
that is a little less bizarre than some
of the straightforward ones that are
worried about like infinite like sort of
infinitely small probabilities of crazy
things happening that can kind of mess
up your a decision that's not what I'm
talking about since we're talking about
transformational experiences what better
time to think about life insurance I
know pretty good segue huh policy genius
is a wonderful way to pick out the life
insurance plan that is right for you or
whatever other kind of insurance you're
looking for home disability auto etc the
point is that policy genius is not the
insurance company they're a way to
figure out which of the various
insurance companies are offering the
kind of plan that you want in minutes
you can compare quotes from a bunch of
different insurers find your best price
and then the policy genius team will
handle all the paperwork and red tape
life insurance is a weird thing you
don't want to contemplate this kind of
thing but it's much better to have it it
gives you a little bit of peace of mind
as well as helping your loved ones down
the line so if you've been thinking
about doing this getting life insurance
or getting any other kind of insurance
now would be the time don't get
discouraged look at the different
options think about what you need at
policy genius calm it just takes a few
minutes to find your best price and
apply it's difficult to know what's
gonna happen in the future you might as
well get your life insurance right
I guess what I have in mind is the I
guess is a semi-famous example where you
tried to buy a house and you put in a
bid and someone else puts in a bid
there's just a little bit more and you
can't match it you can't quite afford it
and I think that you know the sort of
rational utility maximizing would say
well you shouldn't be sad about that
because if you had paid more money you'd
that would be worse than but you are sad
about it because you didn't get the
house so somehow like a tiny change in
what happens leads to a huge change in
how you feel about it so is that a flaw
in the rational decision theory kind of
stuff is that just a flaw in human
beings and how they think about the
world it's a good question I think it
depends on how we tell the story so if
if if it's the case that there was some
change that then adjust so you got more
information and that adjusted your
preferences in some way then you read
what happens is that you have to do a
wrist if you did a reassessment you
would maximize utility by spending more
and getting the house well then it's
then it's rational to go wanted to do
that if instead there really is no
change in your preferences but there's
some other kind of psychological bias or
some kind of regret or other kinds of
things happening then it's not rational
to like fail to to be set it's not
rushed would you sad that you didn't get
the house are we but are we defining
rationality to be that course it is a
true feature of rationality um well okay
so there are subtle questions here I
think that okay to two issues one is
that we want to distinguish between what
you might think if there's a kind of
normative or kind of objective standard
of rationality and then what agents do
in particular situations given their
different human psychology and like kind
of trying to do the best they can in
very circumstances that's the kind of
more subjective sense of being rational
we can come back to that but it's also
the case that there's a lot of things
that go into decision making and so what
I was trying to work was a very simple
idea that choosing rationally involves
maximizing utility or maximizing your
expected utility and that as long as
we're doing that then we're doing
something that in some sense approaches
like rational action yet like you said
you're trying to raise a new problem for
that which is that
tell me what it is yeah okay so um
actually let me give you a quick
definition personal tell us okay so so
when I was talking about these
experiences of becoming a vampire or
becoming a parent for the first time I
described them as epistemic lis
transformative in my work and what I
mean by that is that they change how you
think in a certain way they give you new
information they teach you something new
in virtue of having these experiences
but right but it's not just new
information it's a new way of thinking
indeed by that yeah exactly well I mean
the way that it's complicated and
psychologically so in virtue of having
this new kind of experience I think if
it's especially if it's an intense
experience it does change how you think
now you can like try new kind of food
and it might just give you new
information and it will give you new
abilities to imagine food like that but
it doesn't change or restructure I think
how you think about yourself act Lee
right but when it scales up into what's
also a personally transformative
experience again like becoming a vampire
becoming a parent then the radical
discovery epistemic discovery that you
make also then affects you in a very
strong way thus changing the way that
you understand yourself or how you think
and your preferences okay so once we
have that in play right and remember
what's really important is that you have
to have the experience so it's like not
like someone can tell you in the
relevant sense what the experience is
going to be like yeah ask somebody else
exactly
exactly well they're a vampire and
they're gonna say you just won't get it
man you're just not exactly exactly I
mean they can say oh it's great and saw
these things but that's not enough I
have another example to try to bring
that out in a second but um so the
thought is just going back to the
rationality question if I if there's
something that this dramatic thing that
I can't know about beforehand then
there's a way in which I can't assign it
value that's the first part of the
transformative experience issue that's
relevant for their decision-making
because I can't then assign value to the
outcome but the other part that's really
important is because of this new
information is so important to you or
affects you psychologically so much it
changes how you think and that changes
your preferences right so there's this
kind of one-two punch that
that you get when you have a
transformative experience drinking blood
is gross to me now but it would be
awesome to me once I were a vampire so
exactly judge exactly and because you
can't project yourself remodel yourself
forward as a vampire there's a way in
which you can't see how who you're gonna
become right from the inside and that's
that's part of what I find so
fascinating about these cases so that's
a different kind of objection from the
kinds of worries about just kind of
getting a model that's gonna fit the
situation in the right way like gif in
like oh well there could be these other
probabilities or sometimes we
psychologically we have these biases or
regret or things like that those are all
important questions but I'm adding this
one yeah to the mix and I also think
it's something that people face in real
life all the time and kind of goes
unnoticed and relates to how we praise
people and blame people and things like
that so I wanted to talk about it well
the other aspect that that seems
crucially important here maybe this is
jumping ahead but that's okay it's a
podcast not only rationality but the
idea that is it my preferences now that
matter or my preferences in the future
because what does that say about the
notion of quote unquote my preferences
in the future as I could be a different
person and and how do i define myself
over time exact for those of us who care
about the many-worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics this is already an
important question so for those of us
who care about just one world making our
decisions probably it's another
important question how does my how this
many worlds cool okay so no this is
exactly right so there's a way and this
is related this is part of the the worry
for a decision making because this issue
about self change like Who I am now ex
ante right I'm thinking about what I
care about and how I want my life to go
the defined ex ante for Who I am now
before I've undergone any changes as I'm
making the choice right I try to think
about what it would be like to be a
vampire and imagine just like the nature
of this life that I'm considering it and
the problem is is that if I choose to
become a vampire
it will change not just like my species
I'll be you know become a vampire
instead of
human but I'll also change how I think
so there's a violation of what's called
act state independence normally when
you're when you think about like when
you're trying to test something
ordinarily and you want to see well if I
do this
well I'll see this effect so you tweak
one thing and you see if there's a tweak
like down the line right and then if you
if there is then you've established a
certain kind of dependence
if you hadn't tweaked especially and
then I wouldn't have been that other
tweak and then you can make certain
kinds of inferences about that but that
assumes that nothing Crazy's gonna
change in between yeah but in this case
this case of making a transformative
choice right it's exactly a case where
you're choosing an outcome but you are
gonna get tweaked right but has usually
so so the agent is changed right in
virtue of making the choice and so then
it's unclear first what we can infer
from the fact that down the line the new
agent is satisfied for the choice
because with that old agent have been
satisfied with the choice and this
matters from a rational a rational
decision model perspective because the
person making the choice is the one
who's supposed to be acting rashly and
they have to make the right choice for
themselves ex ante so but really what
they're doing is making them maybe the
right choice for themselves ex post
after the decision right I mean maybe
maybe we could just talk at a very
elementary level about what it means to
be a self over time right you know we're
the same atoms but not exactly because
you know some atoms we lose some atoms
we gain and we certainly are a slightly
different person five minutes from now
than we are right now why does it even
make sense to treat ourselves as a
unified individual over time well fair
enough
I think that there are lots of ways in
which people change I distinguish
between the selves that realize a person
over time and being the same person
although ordinary language doesn't make
that distinction and it just gets
ambiguous with ordinary language but we
do change I get my haircut you know you
buy new clothes whatever but the way I'm
thinking about the self here is
primarily in terms of one's first-person
experience of themselves and the nature
of their life
and I think this is something that's
obviously very important to us it's
especially important in kind of Western
context one might say where we have a
lot of choice over our lives and we take
a lot of personal responsibility based
on these choices so another thing that's
important here is I'm interested in in
in cases where it's sort of morally open
to you to do different things so there's
no moral or legal obligation to choose
one way or the other and I take in many
cases like the choice to become a parent
like that there's gonna be not illegal
yeah yeah I mean there are moral
arguments but I'm studying some of that
aside for the moment so like these kinds
of choices that are kind of self
oriented or self involved in the sense
that you're making a choice about you
and your life and a choice that can
affect close others so like for example
if you choose to bring a child in into
the world well then that other people
and so the thought is that there's a
natural sense in which we think of
ourselves like from the inside as that's
kind of I don't know consciousness
moving forward in time somehow and we
want it to be relatively continuous we
wrote we reckoned there are changes but
we want it to be relatively continuous
and I also think of like what we care
about how we value things as an
important part of what we take to be
kind of who we are and we want that to
be continuous or at least if we're not
gonna make it continuous that we know
what we're doing when we're changing
yeah yeah so this this opens up I mean
maybe the vampire example is already
good enough but we can think of other
examples like taking some kind of happy
pills that just you know they make you
happy like certainly we see other people
who take them and they're perfectly
happy but they also have bad
consequences nominally like they're just
people become indolent and they stop
exercising and they eventually die
within a few months right right but if
you asked any of them they say oh yeah
this is great the happy pills are
awesome and so it would seem that from
our present perspective not taking the
pills we don't want to do that even
though they all say it's a good idea is
that a good example that is that is a
really good example I'm interested in
cases where from the outside it seems to
pretty much everyone that this person
should
have made the choice that they made but
they are actually once they've made the
choice and they before they made the
choice would have rejected it but then
somehow they they find themselves in
that new situation maybe they have an
accident or they make the choice under
certain kinds of circumstances and
they're happy with it and I'm super
interested in how we judge that and how
we think about that and whether it
really is the wrong choice right I think
it's an open question can I give you my
go back to my parenting example okay so
one case I'm really interested in is
where say somebody doesn't want to have
a child because let's say she has the
opportunity as the mode means an
opportunity for murders but sure doesn't
want to do it but her parents are like
oh you'll be so happy as a mother you'll
be you know it'll really make you feel
like a complete person you know yada
yada yeah the whole story and she says
look mom earlier she was talking about
being a vampire with her mom and I'm
talking about like having a kid right um
I see the parents on the playground they
look you know with the kids they look
exhausted people every parent I know
just complains about how they don't get
any sleep and about how stressful it is
how the child is crying or cranky and
they are worried about money and they're
having career issues I mean why would I
want to do this yeah and the mom says
well yeah yeah I understand that you're
making uh you're making sacrifices but
once you become a parent you'll enjoy it
you'll love it yeah exactly
this is exactly the kind of change of
self that I'm interested in because
let's say that that the that your mother
is right right you know I mean it's the
descriptive fact if they're wrong easy
yeah exactly exactly then it's easy no
problem but the interesting case is when
they're right and that's a version of
the happy pill yeah
but the happy pill stuff there are kind
of cultural reasons why people might
want to choose against that so why I
like the parenting case is I think it's
a it's a really open question yeah where
people have the right to not become
parents and have good lives that way
people have the right to become parents
have good lives that way so it's not
simple and I think that probably the
obvious response to the question about
transformative experience for a lot of
the audience for me certainly when I
first started thinking about this is
can't you just ask people
can you just sort of you know gather
data from a third-person perspective and
what you're saying is you know that's
not quite enough I mean that the happy
pills certainly a very obvious example
of that
you can ask them and they're they're
perfectly happy but the parenting
example is quite analogous and and quite
much more realistic where it's it can be
a difficult question that's right I mean
if something about the process of
becoming transformed makes you value the
the end process in a way that your
present self does not in a way that your
present self doesn't utterly rejects in
fact then this needs to be factored in
to the decision so one thing that I've
been discussing with transformative
experiences like there's this is to say
well maybe because of this violation of
act state independence that I mentioned
earlier then there's this possibility
that a new preference is kind of
implanted in you in virtue of undergoing
the experience and that just changes how
we should evaluate testimony it changes
how we should praise and blame people
for the choices that they make okay all
kinds of things let me pause for a
second to talk about LinkedIn jobs if
you're like me you've been on LinkedIn
for a very long period of time even if
you're not applying for jobs or looking
for jobs there's still a lot of useful
services there LinkedIn jobs is for
people who want to be on the other side
of the hiring equation if you want to
hire someone LinkedIn jobs gives you a
wonderful way to find the right
candidate you can figure out what it is
the skills that you really value for the
job you're looking for whether it's
collaboration creativity experience
adaptability LinkedIn looks beyond the
work skills and puts your job post in
front of the qualified candidates who
match your requirements perfectly it's
no wonder that a person is hired every
eight seconds with LinkedIn and why
companies rate Lincoln jobs the number
one hiring platform for delivering
quality hires so you can find the right
person for your business today with
LinkedIn jobs and you can pay what you
want and get the first fifty dollars off
by visiting linkedin.com slash mindscape
again that's linkedin.com slash
mindscape to get $50 off your first job
post terms and conditions apply
is it is there again probably skipping
ahead but is there a simple answer I
don't I don't I mean I have I make some
suggestions in my book transformative
experience where I say one way to
approach this is to kind of be open to
the way that your preferences and who
you are is going to change if you make a
transformative if you make a
transformative choice and to see that as
what you're doing like you're just
discovering a new self or you're
choosing to discover a new self process
of changing has an intrinsic value
something like that I mean I don't I
have I'm still thinking about it and
this was at the end of the discussion
basically developing all the structure
of the transformative experience but a
puzzle in terms of decision making it
seems to me that there is a way you can
rationally approach these things and
that is being open to these
possibilities and discovering who you
become maybe because it's intrinsically
valuable to have those experiences I'm
not even sure we have to say that but
that I do I am owning it that way but I
don't think that's that's satisfying as
a final solution you put it in a
language at one point about trying to be
empathetic with your future self right I
mean trying to imagine what it would be
like I do want to dig in a little bit to
these questions of the self and also the
phrase what it would be like right this
reminds us of on the podcast we've had
previous discussions about consciousness
David Chalmers and Phillip Gough and
Daniel Dennett in different ways talking
about qualia and inner experience and
the famous Mary the color scientist
argument you know experiencing the
redness of red is there a secret or
not-so-secret relationship between those
kind of first-person perspective
arguments and what we're talking about
here there's a relationship but what I
did with my work was to take those
discussions about consciousness and
tweak them pretty significantly because
those debates are about whether or not
we can kind of make sense or explain
from a kind of
physical or neural perspective you know
what it's like or what it's like to have
experiences and what I I'm not really
I'm not making that kind of argument or
I'm not that's not really about
physicalism versus pants I'm interested
if you take the Mary case where Mary
grasp on a black and white environment
and then I think that as well maybe she
has the choice to leave her black and
white room and if the question is what
does she want to like live in a world of
color and but I'm not interested in like
at the end of all science let's just say
she's ordinary in some sense ordinary
Mary now we don't have all the brain
science to even know what her brain
States will be like she has testimony
from people who live outside but she
could find it like overwhelming and
stressful and there's a way in which
like she can't assign value to these
different color experiences just doesn't
know she doesn't even have technically
like the right kind of phenomenal
hypotheses to consider and so she can't
make the decision in a suitably informed
way she it's kind of flip a coin or just
do it if she wants to find out what it's
like like I'm saying but that's like the
same solution maybe to becoming a parent
or becoming a vampire so there's a
connection there one way I kind of put
it is I think of the problem of it's not
about consciousness per se but the
problem of other minds and knowing what
other people are like from the inside
and when we're undergoing these radical
self changes we turned that problem into
a problem of knowing the minds of other
of your other cells right it's the same
problem but your pqube not even your
simple actual future self but you have
sort of different alternatives to go
down yes which reminds me I'm not sure
if this is related or not but I did have
a fascinating podcast interview with
Malcolm McIver
who is thinking about the evolution of
consciousness over time and he makes the
claim that a crucial step there's
probably many steps along the way but a
crucial step was when fish climbed onto
land because when fish are underground
underground underwater you can't see
very far ahead of you and all the
evolutionary pressure is just to make
decisions right away when you have a new
stimulus come into your sensorium
whereas when you're on land you can see
far and now you have enough time to
contemplate different possible actions
so and he's actually made predictions
that have come true in the fossil record
and things like that and the idea is
that suddenly the ability to imagine
alternative futures becomes a good thing
and therefore evolution selects for it
and and this is kind of what we're
challenging here the ability to
accurately imagine possible futures
that's fascinating and so but one thing
that's really a big part of my work is
to say that when we're talking about
like life-changing decisions and
especially it's going to go back to
context where there are hard trade-offs
to be made so I mean I'm kind of an
academic woman with a career so I'm a
person who that's very salient to
because the world is not carved up in a
way like for me to make my life choices
yeah right exactly and different kinds
of people have faced different kinds of
this in different ways you know and but
if it's not if the world isn't kind of
made isn't carved up so that it's the
choices are really easier there are no
big trade-offs or there's no like time
to deliberate then that affects like the
way that we're thinking about things
obviously but and when when we really do
care about what's gonna happen over a
reasonably sort of long time future
period and I think it's we think it's
actually intrinsically valuable like it
relates the way that we think about who
we are and how we evaluate life and
authentic kind of living in choice
making which sounds like there's an
interesting evolutionary connection
fascinating yeah when we're in that kind
of context is when these sorts of
problems become especially salient is
there is it valid in this context to
even think of ourselves even at one
moment of time as a unified self I mean
you do talk a little bit about the fact
that sometimes we know to do something
is irrational but we just have an
overwhelming compulsion to do it anyway
like I know in this household what we're
doing is podcast there is a prescription
against buying lime dusted tortilla
chips because there's a bag of lime dust
the tortilla right away and it's bad to
you and you know so just don't buy them
in the first place right so yeah like I
might know that there's a rational
decision to be made but I can't because
real people are not quite that rational
how does that come into these kinds of
deliberations well I say by the way my
weakness is New York super fudge chunk
okay that's a very good so this goes
back to the distinction I was making
between of
detective characterizations of rational
decision-making and subjective ones
there's a way in which part of what I'm
super interested in is the sub like what
it's like for us as individuals faced
with different possibilities to think
through our choices and then make a
choice as rationally as we can in the
moment and we're imperfect agents and
we're often in imperfect circumstances
there's been lots of research on like
perfect agents what they should do in
perfect circumstances that's kind of
like objective rationality and then
there's lots of research on like what
the perfect agent should do in imperfect
circumstances and I think there's
research on what imperfect agents should
do in perfect circumstances but that
last box of the it hasn't been filled in
and that's really where I'm targeting
the project so so I want to grant that
there are all these imperfections that
sometimes we just kind of can't help
ourselves and do these kinds of things
but I'm not really thinking about those
kinds of cycle like that kind of
particular kind of psychological
weakness the kind of imperfection that
I'm really interested in is one where
just because we haven't had the
background experiences like we lack the
ability to imagine what we need yeah one
favorite example I have is of someone
who grows up congenitally blind and then
has the opportunity to like through
having a retina operation or something
that's become sighted they might know
from actually from testimony from people
who've had the operation that they will
that they will regret that operation
this is something that does happen and
yet they might really want to do it even
though there's a really deep sense in
which they don't know what its gonna be
like and maybe they want to do because
they want to discover like what it's
like to see but they might also just be
thinking I can't you know I know that
the nature of my life will be better
somehow or I think it will be better in
any case there's a sense in which
they're an imperfect agent making a
choice because they're choosing to have
this new sense capacity and they don't
have the ability to evaluate the nature
of that sense capacity until they
actually have it I do feel like there
there should be even if we grant that
when you change in some transformative
way you have different values right you
you care about
different things I maybe this is wrong
but I want to think there's something
more objective going on I mean I think
the happy pills are a hypothetical
example but there are drug addicts right
there are people who become heroin
addicts and most people who are not
heroin addicts do not want to be heroin
addicts plain the people who are heroin
addicts really want that heroin right
and I so is there no standpoint outside
of the first-person perspective where
you could say no one is just better than
the other oh I do think that I don't
want to dismiss at all both the
importance of testimony what we can know
in general from kind of sign from
science and also these basic these facts
about kind of quality of life and
well-being so with the heroin addiction
case I think the hard case by the way is
that at the end of life end of life
cases where there aren't other people
depending on you and where you're not
going to kind of miss out on various
kinds of resources and whether or not
you want to become a heroin addict there
is a more salient oh I see so you got
end-of-life in terms of whether to end
it but yeah you know by going into
hospice or something like that because
you have a terminal disease yeah but so
so I think that like with the with the
way that I want to think about like a
drug addiction case is that we know
objectively that most of those options
are bad and addiction is funny because
they're it's not clear that the choice
involved that we have enough kind of
freedom mentally to be making the choice
and the way that I'm suggesting we make
it where you carefully evaluate each
option and trade-off with wouldn't that
be an example of something that we're
holding up objectively that there's a
certain transformative experience it
takes away our ability to make choices
or something yeah yeah a good point yes
that's right that's right but then when
somebody becomes addicted and they've
lost in some sense they're related to
make certain kinds of choices and they
also enjoy like the hi and they don't
want to to leave that space well I think
actually we need to have more
understanding of that I think there's a
lot of blame that gets attached to
someone being in that state and also
people can't understand why that person
in that state fine like find it valuable
don't they understand it it kind of
feels good or whatever but there's a way
in which they don't understand
and I actually think that this is this
needs more assessment not like you know
endorsing becoming getting addicted to
heroin but I think that weird way too
judgmental about these kinds of cases
and I'm fascinated with cases of
disability partly because I think that
people who have like undergone traumatic
traumatic accidents or who have who are
just have different kind of physical
characteristics from kind of you know I
don't know bog-standard
ordinary you know human beings testify
to how amazing their lives are in
various contexts and I think that people
who don't share their physical
characteristics fail to understand what
they're talking about there's a kind of
testimonial injustice involved here is
there a strategy for doing better other
than just talking more people and trying
to be empathetic well for me the first
strategy is understanding this issue
about transformative experience like not
assuming that like I think there's a
kind of epistemic humility that we need
to engage in so you know by thinking
well I can learn everything I need to
know about like what it's like to be a
parent by talking to people I can learn
everything I know about what it's like
to be blind by talking to applying
people or whatever you know to pick your
category right I think is I think we're
too optimistic sometimes that we can do
that and this is related to thing I said
about praise and blame because sometimes
people choose to do things or refuse to
do things thinking that with testimony
they have all of the information that
they need I think they have some of the
information they need but not that
first-person no that's professor and
then again just to emphasize it you know
the the mentioning the first-person
perspective is something that is
intrinsically different than the
third-person perspective is not to
mystify what it means to be conscious or
experience right exactly it's a
different thing like yeah mary has not
seen the color red that I'm very happy
to admit that she does not know what
it's like to experience the color red
and that's that's all I need to get to
go often I'm all for running that I mean
you can see my project as I love
contemporary kind of academic philosophy
but for the longest time the only way we
were allowed to talk about first-person
experience and phenomenology was in the
context of the question about
consciousness okay and that's a very
port and discussion and I always loved
all the examples like Nagel Tom Nagel
and others talking about local maybe you
couldn't know what it's like to be a bat
or maybe couldn't know what's like to be
an octopus or Mary in the black my super
cool examples but like look there's just
so much more that's interesting there
that's not gonna happen to me like I'm
not gonna be offered the opportunity to
become a bat together you'll be offered
the opportunity to you know change jobs
or have a kid go to war maybe all these
kinds you know and an end of life
questions I think are incredibly
important like facing potential like
cognitive decline or dealing with an
accident and I think we need to
understand when we can't understand and
then change how we approach things is
there some possibility for a new way of
making judgments that is not either
purely based on testimony or
first-person perspective I'm totally
just babbling right now the only thing
okay so here's the only kind of third
way that that that I have come across
that has some potential but I don't I
don't think it's good enough it's
thinking about the roles like art and so
there are ways in which we try to
communicate like sometimes the whole
point of kind of working artists to
communicate something that couldn't be
expressed through ordinary tests like
you know testimony and decryption
right and sometimes use language in
evocative ways and then use other media
in evocative ways and that that's
important because it teaches us
something about how to experience and
value often often it's like something
that we're familiar with and we can find
the art very very powerful that way but
sometimes it's you know what we're not
familiar with right yeah and so it's
kind of our art can be kind of an
empathy pump right you can order to help
us empathize with people in very
different circumstances exactly and to
understand things that we that are kind
of you know beyond our own individual
experiences that said it's not enough I
mean you know I can read all of the
novels I want about like what it's like
to be diagnosed with terminal cancer or
you know watch amazing films about going
to war but if I go to like a Vietnam vet
say oh yeah man you know I get it I know
it was like yeah you know
I mean that would be embarrassing
but it's still the case that I did learn
something so it's complicated
it's always interesting to me that
almost every depiction on TV or movies
of being the parent of a young child
makes it look horrible right like
there's very few attempts to capture the
joy of it right or the value of it I
mean maybe I don't know why but it's
just more community or something well so
here's an extra thing that we haven't
talked about yet but I think there's
this other dimension to it and it's
related to doing stuff based on
testimony which is um sometimes we
choose to do things that involve
suffering and we find it kind of value
in that suffering and it's not
straightforward to explain why that is
or why we're doing it so with a happy
pill so sorry sometimes it is like you
know you work out and you know some
people like working out others like okay
it's a slog but there's some future
benefit that is clear oh you're saying
that there's even when there's not a
clear future benefit sometimes we do
this that's right even if you think
there isn't a clear future benefit in a
certain way there's a way in which the
nice people choose to suffer and they
choose to reduce their well-being along
a certain dimension and they find that
meaningful and valuable and I don't
think when I mention some examples here
well I actually what I'm thinking about
well parenting is like that maybe okay
or other aspects of many yeah I have too
many aspects or like that but you get a
kind of parenting does have lots of
straightforward joy with it but there
are lots of choices we make - so the
happy pill was actually a kind of a
simple examples like let's say that um
if I had a tendency towards depression I
don't I'm sort of actually annoyingly
cheerful if I had a tendency towards um
getting depressed but I could take meds
that would keep that at bay in a very
strong sense right um but it would
change how I experience my life and in
fact I might think oh yeah I'll be
happier but just like a little bit less
on top of things a little bit less savvy
and sophisticated
a little less of me right I might refuse
I think this does happen to take the
meds and suffer right and it's because
there's a sense in which I find even
though there's suffering there I still
find it kind of more meaningful to live
my life that way mm-hmm then the way
that in art you know arguably it's gonna
like increase my well-being unlike most
ordinary scales I think that's actually
super common right people not just with
depression but with bipolar disorders or
something like that they say yeah these
meds keep me level but they take away
something of who I was and and part of
what you're saying is not necessarily
that's right or wrong but at least we
should contemplate taking that claims
and this goes back to some of the stuff
about disability so like a blind person
who then becomes sighted right can I
think very recently feel first they've
lost they lose certain capacities in
virtue of gaining vision and they can
feel that or this comes up in the
context of cochlear implants and people
wanting you know trying to decide
whether or not their child should have a
cochlear implant and become a member of
a community with kind of ordinary
language an ordinary audition or it may
be a part of the deaf community all
these issues come into play because it's
not a straightforward situation where
there's a simple way of thinking about
like well-being sometimes there's you
have to make these kinds of trade-offs
and there's a kind of meaningfulness
that's associated maybe with say being a
member of the deaf community or you know
being a member of the blind community
that gives you a kind of richness and
meaning that it's not detectable to
someone who isn't a part of that
community probably another example is
autistic people versus neurotypical
people and different ways of thinking is
it really better or worse or is it just
different how do you know how could you
possibly know absolutely and a thing to
remember about the people who are some
would say someone who's like on the
spectrum is that I think there's a very
good argument that it's the way that
society is structured as opposed to how
they're mentally structured that really
creates many of the issues here and so
when we go back to what I was saying
before that choices often involve are
hard choices are often hard because the
world is structured in a particular way
and maybe you don't fit into that
structure straightforwardly
then all of a sudden then we get faced
with these special and difficult choices
we have to make and again I just think
that being really clear about the
conceptual structure of these problems
and the epistemological hurdles we have
to overcome and the self change involved
will allow us to be like less judgmental
and more thoughtful about how we
understand the different ways people
have to navigate the environment right
and so you do have one example that is
especially provocative and I'm sure you
chose it intentionally for this reason
of atheist / skeptics and the
possibility of them opening themselves
to a sense of the divine and saying that
you know well I'll let you say it howdy
how would you put it okay so this is
from the my new book when I haven't
published yet that I'm working on that
should come out soon and there I explore
sorry we should mention you have a book
out an academic book yeah transformative
experience does talk about these things
anyone the audience yes yes but I don't
talk about religious transformation in
my new book I apply what I've been
saying about transformative experience
not so much about decision making
straightforwardly but just about
transformative experience and how we
think about it and understand it - two
questions about religious transformation
and tolerance I'm very interested in
those kinds of cases and I I don't think
that I'm describing all issues about
skepticism versus belief here but
there's a particular kind of debate that
you see get carried out sometimes
between a short like a believer in a
particular religious faith and a strong
skeptic
the atheist who's committed just
rejecting you know the idea that there's
a God and one of the things that
fascinates me about the about the kind
of debate that you sometimes see is that
it doesn't evidence doesn't seem to
matter relevant it's not right an
argument is not going to convince people
right and the skeptic and / - there's
this kind of skeptical stance where the
skeptic things look I'm the clear
thinker I'm the one who
[Laughter]
I'm the one who who really is you know
careful and facing the hard facts of
reality and it's the believer who you
know needs comfort or whatever right and
so I mean IIIi see that point of view
but I'm I'm suspicious of it as a kind
of straightforward explanation of how to
and a good self is consistent skeptic
should themselves be yes skeptical of
yes suspicious of it are we sure we're
not fooling ourselves exactly exactly so
what I explore in the book is a
particular argument that certain that
basically theologians and
epistemologists have explored and what I
look at in particular is one that
descends from the Calvinist tradition
because John Calvin had this view about
the census Divina Titus and this is
about the sense of the divine and very
roughly his view was that we have this
sense within us but it has to be awoken
I believe he thought that it was kind of
lost in the fall from grace
right and there are ways that you can
awaken this sense of the divine
including you know being kind of out in
nature and seeing the beauty of nature
and that can awaken our capacity to
recognize the divine like in nature and
other kinds of things and once we
recognize the divine our capacity to see
the presence of God and to recognize
evidence is awakened and we're naturally
moved to believe the kind of American
advocate of this originally was Jonathan
Edwards as a Protestant theologian and
about the presidential candidate no no
and I'm actually a member of Jonathan
Edwards college at Yale and it was you
don't need to be a Calvinist to be no no
no no no and and Alvin Plantinga
is a philosopher and theologian who also
advocated this and Edwards talked about
the sense divinity Attis and the idea
was that you were supposed to kind of
engage in certain practices to awaken
this sense right and you can find this
by the way in other traditions I think
he found it in Judaism another can you
know expressed in different ways
the ideas that practice and certain kind
of actions you perform can awaken and
and intensify your sense of the divine
and there's a clear analogy with a blind
person exactly discovering see a rainbow
or something like that or or Mary right
and right is there's a kind of what
happens is you have you open your mind
in a certain way to having an experience
that experience is novel and distinctive
Edwards talked about it as though like
you were tasting honey for the first
time plant think I actually use the
example of seeing read for the first
time must've known what he was doing
maybe I mean he doesn't I I think so but
I'm not sure shal philosopher what he
knew he was well when I say I'm sure he
was brilliant I'm sure that he knew that
he I mean he was intentionally like
harking back to the Jackson example but
I I don't think he was thinking in terms
of transformative experience exploit Lee
although yet I don't know how it his
work is fascinating so but and what
plant acai did so beautifully in his
work was to explain that look um you
have to be able to detect evidence
before you can even see it as such so
the thought is that the believer says
look you need to open your mind in the
right way to engage your state to awaken
the sensitive inner tatis and then you
can recognize the evidence of the divine
and we move to faith so okay so go back
to the skeptic right what I'm interested
in is the skeptic who refuses to make
that move and I think there's a real
question why would a skeptic refuse to
make that move and I think now we can
see now that we have the apparatus of
transparent of experience like why they
might do that because if they sorry I
mean let's just get on the table that it
it's not about divine persuasion or
anything like that where where both
sides are accepting that we should be
rational about the evidence yes that's
right that's right which evidence we
have well what you're what is what is
yeah what what do I take to be evidence
or what is the evidence in some sense
yes which evidence do we have
and if the believer says to the skeptic
well you have to open your mind first to
the sensitive notice or to the right
things to the ear sensitive in atados
can then detect the evidence right the
skeptic might refuse to do that why
would they refuse to do that they're
supposed to be open-minded and looking
at all the evidence and be super kind of
careful and clear and everything else
and I thought is that well look if
opening your mind to engage the senses
divinity changes who you are and how you
think that's the first part and it's
something that you can't know about
until you open your mind because it's
like tasting honey or seeing color for
the first time then you're risking that
your very self that's the first problem
so you're asking someone to risk their
very self to consider the possibility of
this thing that they don't right now
believe in and second they lose a
certain kind of control of something I
think is deeply important than namely
how they think or at least potentially
from their ex-ante perspective they're
being asked to open their mind up in a
way that it says they can no longer in
some sense control how they believe
about something to have it and through
having an experience that they can't
actually assess the nature of from
within before they do it and I think
these worries seem to make sense whether
or not you believe the senses divin
artists do notice they're not divine at
it let's move on whether it's real or
whether it's just self delusion that's
either way that's once you're there once
either God is talking to you or you've
convinced yourself God is talking to you
you're convinced that's potentially
that's right
no but that's that the whole picture I
mean the argument is supposed to be that
once you engage the senses divinity
Attis that from within you realize oh
this is the way to live one's life now I
see the evidence of the divine all
around me and you're convinced and
you're satisfied and happy from the
outside it looks like a kind of mind
control but from the inside these are
rational thoughtful people who are
believers it's not like you know it's
not like taking a drug it's really not
like taking a drug then from but on the
inside the basically a believer is very
happy
and and and and committed and to for the
way that they understand the way the
world is it's kind of like there are
Fitness landscapes two sets of beliefs
right like in the big picture I called
them planets of belief where you have
different beliefs that sort of fit
together in a nice way and there could
be more than one such planets that are
completely compatible by your lights
with your experience of the world but
they're incompatible with each other
which brings us to kun and theoretical
you know and and having new theories of
the nature of reality right so I think
there's a really strong parallel here to
the kind of radical theoretical change
that can happen in scientific
communities and the kind of radical
belief change that an individual can
undergo and you know just as somebody
who's totally committed let's say to the
Newtonian worldview or their worst
Italian like the like an Aristotelian
perspective on the nature of the
external world is just not going to be
able to make sense of let's say I don't
know a contemporary you know picture of
reality in terms of say quantum
mechanics right it's just not there it's
totally insane from the Aristotelian
don't find the words ya know exactly
exactly and there's a and we we have it
we can understand that right these very
different ways of making sense of the
external world well I feel like the
switch between the believer and the
skeptic is like that it's partly about
thinking in a very radical way about how
the external world would be different
but also we're talking about an internal
revolution as well like how you make
sense of who you are and how you think
about the external world is also
changing so it's even more radical than
the ordinary kind of scientific
conceptual revolution there's also an
obvious analogy of politics right I did
a recent podcast with Ezra Klein about
political polarization and it's it's not
about political disagreement
disagreements always been there but
there has been a rise in recent decades
in polarization in the sense that
different political camps beliefs line
up yes right and then once you're in
that world you don't even see what the
other world sees anymore I think I think
that there's a direct relationship here
another one of my Yale colleagues
[Laughter]
pretty good
wear so I think that's exactly right see
I think that there's this complex thing
with it with again this is not like a
universal diagnosis but in certain kinds
of cases where these political
differences the thought is like can i
really think myself into someone who's
politically completely opposed to me
because if I do empathize with that
person's perspective if I fully
empathize with that person's perspective
then with that experience of stepping
into their shoes and thinking about how
they live their life change the way that
I think about things and in ways that I
can't right now
endorse you know so I might have a
particular political view about what I
and and be very committed to it
views about say how women should be
treated in certain contexts or
transgender individuals and then if I
really step into the other person's
perspective and kind of take on their
values what if the experience of seeing
the world through their eyes
restructured my own internal preferences
yeah and that would be changed that
would change who I am in a very
important because we define ourselves
partly by our political beliefs other
kinds of things so that makes it
rational a certain way for me who I am
not to want to still be Who I am so
there's a rational way in which I
shouldn't step into the mind of that
other person to the extent that I can
because it might change me but that's
terrible right it's like that just means
that I'm not supposed to be open-minded
somehow right and I guess what I'm
saying is I'm not I'm not setting up a
prescription here but I think we have to
understand that there really is this
barrier and what can drive I think
either a commitment like to the right or
to the left and a refusal to really
really want to see the perspective of
the other side is a certain way in which
we need to protect our own identities
mhm
and so there is a rationale like by
that's my that's right there's a
rational argument for this kind of
refused to be open-minded
that's very I'm not deaf like I think
that we need to find some other way
around it it's disconcerting it's
disconcerting but it's important to
recognize that that's half
because I think people fail to see and
might not even be rushed I mean I mean I
mean it's rational and certainty but I
think there's a very deep we grasp the
rationality but a very deep like
impulsive level I probably I think there
is an imbalance you do say at the end of
a very long discussion that of course
all this is true for the also for the
point of view of the believer
contemplating becoming a skeptic yes yes
there's a symmetry that way there's a
little bit of an asymmetry because by
the self-proclaimed lights of the
skeptic they do have maybe you could
they could be argued into thinking they
have a duty to experience this other way
of looking at the world because their
whole self image is about gathering all
the data and making a good decision but
if the believer thought that putting
themselves in the cognitive space of a
skeptic would cause them to lose their
faith they might think no that I don't I
just don't want to do that I know that's
wrong so like there's a little bit of an
asymmetry there I see but that's a good
point
um I don't think about that some more
because I think there might be other
asymmetries on on on the other side but
I'm not super moved by the skeptical
argument because I think there's a very
very basic way it's kind of interesting
for self preservation that's gonna Trump
even you're kind of high-minded
commitment to evaluate different
person's practical matters for it yeah
well and that's and that's and I'm mr.
day here like in a certain in a kind of
practical way because the believer has
that high-flown argument as well like if
you truly believe in in the divine then
there's a kind of commitment to like you
know seeking divine truth I think that
they might they might try to say if
you're truly committed then you should
be able to go out and risk like you know
viewing a skeptical point mmm of you and
be able to come back but then I'm not
sure maybe good maybe it's differently
of saying it just that um there's some
kind of epistemic barrier to to being
the perfect skeptic who says well I
should experience everything and know
all the different viewpoints and there
are traps like you can't experience all
the different viewpoints yes no I think
that is part of what that is very much
part of what I want to say and again
just bring it back to the practical I
feel like this is this kind of epistemic
humility question and we need to be
clear about these constraints that we
face as
Pratt we don't have a God's eye point of
view we can't take a God's eye point of
view and sometimes see I think sometimes
until like analytic philosophers one
intellectuals we think of ourselves as
like being up like a God's eye as well
and and it's it doesn't mean like it's
not that Oh
and I think that that's a mistake and
it's not a in and sometimes there's you
well if you can't think about these
things Cleary's because you're kind of
stupid or something you limited some
house like well you know what maybe
we're a specifically limited as human
beings but it's not about like
intelligence it's like it's about our
capacities to know things that we
haven't experienced the way the brain
works yeah yeah and you you you seem to
make a great effort of not being to
judge your prescriptive here right and
yeah probably part of that is just
strategic like you want to emphasize
that there is a difficulty that people
aren't even recognizing do you have
secret I mean you know a lot of my work
actually in some ways is very personal
like even though I tried to kind of be
very abstract and I I you have and I try
actually very hard to be empathetic with
lots of different yeah perspectives and
I do a lot of mentoring and teaching for
lots of different reasons I'm often put
in that role isn't actually it
especially one that I even what that I
just end up doing and I think it's
important and like with respect to so
for example I'm very committed
I'm a very pro-choice person but I have
always always been drawn in a certain
way to the arguments you know against
abortion because I have two children I
love them dearly I really do think that
there's a frightening argument involved
about you know ending you know and
ending the viability of a fetus that I
think should be taken seriously but I
don't fully know how to take it
seriously
given my pro-choice commitments so I'm
just speaking great personally here and
so there are other reasons why people
might be kind of you know pro-life and
that sort of thing but I think there is
a really compelling argument at the
heart of those discussions and I'm not
sure I'm able to give it a fair shake
and I I think that's important to
recognize that yeah I mean I think this
is a good sort of takes me to what it
the less I want to talk about the
question of authenticity and you know
even if you don't have a prescription
for how to be perfectly rational in
these possibilities of transformative
experiences there are questions of still
how should we live our lives right like
that's it's kind of a question we have
to answer what do we do right even if I
even if I admit that there's this
lacunae in my possible knowledge I still
gotta act in some way is there some
sense in which being true to ourselves
is the basis for acting or is this also
undermining that because our cells can
change in these interesting ways I think
the way to be true what we have to be
true to is maybe not ourselves but to
our epistemic limitations so so what we
have to recognize is that you know as we
live our lives we change in these
radical ways and we replace all right we
have the chance to replace our current
self with new selves sometimes we do
that we sometimes we don't get to choose
it just happens
and that that's part of what living life
involves that and that we should care
about the nature of lived experience for
ourselves and others and not pretend
that it doesn't matter I think that's
also part of what like and and and
recognize sometimes we're trait when
we're trading off like well-being from
other words but we're making choices to
suffer and this is for me like
philosophy isn't it sometimes about
truth but it's more about wisdom and so
this is the way that I think we can
connect some of these questions about
like rational decision-making and
consciousness and the metaphysics of
selves and persons to authenticity and
being and and and and living our life in
a way that's as wise or informed as we
can in kind of also understand there's a
ton of uncertainty here mm-hmm yeah I
mean that it relates very clearly in my
mind to questions of how to be moral if
you're a naturalist and anti-realist as
I am right you know you
I can I can say sentences and I can I
can in do believe them of the form you
know we have moral inclinations they
come from a bunch of places from
evolution from how we're raised and from
our rational reflection
and even if they're not objectively
grounded out there in the world we can
use them to you know construct a moral
code for ourselves but there is a
foundational problem like where they
come from if they were if I were a very
different person if I had different
genes or different upbringings maybe my
morality would be different isn't that
bad isn't that scary
and now you're saying like I can become
a different person because of something
that happens to me it's now becoming
scarier and scarier you're making my
life harder Laurie that's my job I'm a
philosopher but do you find mean is
there any you know sort of good to use
the word wisdom which is a very good
word to use are there are there words of
wisdom I mean they existentialists talk
about this right you talk about your
relationship to existentialism they seem
to find an answer in authenticity so God
doesn't tell us how to behave but being
our most authentic selves is still the
right way to behave have you pulled that
rug out from under them entirely yeah a
little I hope so I mean my thought is
that authenticity involves understanding
what we can know about ourselves in our
futures and understanding what we can't
know about ourselves in our futures and
coming to terms with that that's it's a
it's a it's a different take you know
any /aa does do you think yes yeah and
then doing doing the best we can doing
the best we can that's a good message we
also actively leave on an optimistic
note so I think we can still do the best
we can and I think that we all agree
that knowing having a more informed
understanding of what the best we can do
is is good mm-hmm right yes yes with the
whole point is that we you get wisdom
and tolerance and a better way of
assessing praise and blame if you know
as much as you can about I think the
Epistle must rush are of what we can't
what what agents are capable of how the
human brain works you know what we can
expect from people and what we can't
expect from people all right something
to chew on okay Laurie Paul thanks so
much for being on this podcast
[Music]
you
[Music]